thil voir cette assemblée à moitié vide
ou à moitié plein seuls 34 élus étaient
autorisés à assister à cette session
plénière aujourd'hui
en réalité cela fait 1 sur 3 et les
absences ont représenté par ses droits
et ses main levée les masques de
sécurité ne passe pas inaperçu c'est
justement le message que certains
veulent faire passer si nous avions fait
fonctionner avec 100 conseillers
régionaux à 50 centimètres l'un de
l'autre sans masque sans liquide pour se
nettoyer des mages comprends qu'on qu'il
y à un procès qu'ils soient faits mais
en l'occurrence travailler et respecter
les règles de sécurité c'est aussi une
façon de dire qu'il faut que la france
rentre petit à petit dans le travail pas
de procès mais un début de polémique
il ya ceux qui voulaient être exemplaire
auprès des citoyens qui continuent de
travailler et ceux qui voulaient au
contraire être exemplaire auprès des
citoyens confiné c'est important qu'on
soit là tous les travailleurs
aujourd'hui sont sollicités en tout cas
ceux qui sont utiles donc à l'activité
économique est essentielle
la démocratie ne doit pas être confiné
la démocratie elle ne doit pas rester
chez elles dont nous avions les moyens
de faire autrement et de statuer et donc
de permettre aussi à la région de
prendre les décisions politiques pour
soutenir l'activité parce que c'est
l'argument qui est donné en face si on
ne s'était pas réunie on n'aurait pas pu
aussi bien entendu on aurait très bien
pu prendre les mêmes délibération en
visio d'autres régions telles fait le
choix des visioconférences
mais la présidente marine dufay a
tranché au sein de sa majorité pourtant
l'assemblée en présentiel pose est aussi
question
j'étais plutôt favorable je le redis à
un système en visio mais l'important
c'était qu'on puisse exprimer le soutien
de conseil régional de cette majorité
visiblement d'une bonne partie de
l'opposition à ces mesures importantes
en faveur de l'économie du monde
associatif des sites web 70 millions
d'euros seront accordés notamment aux
agriculteurs au tourisme et aux
associations